hi everyone hi I'm Doreen T I'm Joe and
together we make Zoran tea and Jess
MacDonald forests welcome back to
another episode everyone and thanks for
joining us it is my turn to sit in the
pilot's seat today and I've brought a
surprise yeah what is it
it's look nemesis and I say it's a
surprise because it's actually a game I
like and it's an adventure game games
that employed the use of live actors so
if you did not hear what the lady was
saying at the beginning she was
basically telling us that the land has
been cursed at the moment okay and
you've been sent to investigate this
strange place in the hopes of curing the
curse I also really extremely like
puzzles yes I don't know how people were
able to solve this game on their own
because it was ridiculously complex yeah
when the Sun and Moon are join into the
entrance to eternity is open colonel
so we need to get inside this puzzle is
actually probably the easiest one to
start you off yeah there's the moon and
look at joined the Sun oh my god
going through hahaha it's a naked man
like ten minutes into the stream and
we've already got a naked man there you
go yeah I'm scared maybe if I go the
other way so you guys can't see they
were playing in a window oh my god
chapter 1 on taxes oh good we got a
thing yeah the other clock that looks
exactly the same as this yeah that's
what you cannot solve and return to me
I've got the hints and I'll give you
three touch me then okay she's the hint
lady
so there are four bodies here in each of
the corresponding to one element okay
okay because they were alchemists she
must be hard to act in a box
okay okay okay mass amanda says act your
way out of this box to time that didn't
make logical sense
oh yeah general area I have a 360 degree
Anglia
Oh you taking time when you go around so
you actually need to cut
and then you have your water element
free the others please okay all right we
have to I think we have to get all the
blue ones lit up something so you when
you click ones man these ones are just
quick everything until it works I think
this is a pen paper sit down give
everything in DUMBO kind of puzzle and
what Ben is the color of the wind is
that a hint yep that sucks play with the
Stars yeah I am mm-hmm make the blue
stars glow alone so it's a very
different puzzle the blue stars telling
me what to do
well it must be wit must be doing fire
right now for illuminating the darkness
yes actually I think it is fire so fire
was I think fire is that one yeah
yeah yeah I must be in a book or
something okay okay then
Oh blind experimentation sold out again
it works hope you die
fingers crossed that is a long trip just
sounds like death sure why not
anything good more acting oh my god
maybe they should let someone else it
gets easy
oh yeah element mom novels bad guy or
bad guy Shane said put it into first
how to drive so the way this works is
you can travel to each of the planets
okay
why is shining the Sun Wow that's
complicated and each one represents each
elements in this full planets you can go
suit and it's actually the origins of
those four people
all right this is air I like their best
cause it was the scariest yeah this
freaked me out big time as a kid yeah
you can carry everything in your pockets
yeah I get to be a ridiculous
okay Oh a key yeah that was every time
we comment to safes in house of ours
well I kind of safes work again we need
to take a class or some [ __ ]
just read that 36 yep 24
it'll zap that
36:20 gives us the key
oh we cleaned up for us all right we're
all the way up on level 20 oh it's how
babies are made
kurz babies why do I need to see this
oh my god
they're inseminating huh really coming
back please sit down
the fear you're feeling now is far far
worse than anything I'm going to do to
you just did that to me Oh God oh my god
I never got to do this
yes emesis yeah we have really just
touched the tip of the iceberg for that
game as well but as usual let us know
what you thought of the stream in the
comments both on YouTube and GameSpot
and with the HOH Alive hashtag we'll be
back again next week if you have any
particular requests for games that you'd
like to see do let us know otherwise we
hope to see you again same time same day
yeah bye everyone
thank you